I want to show you a
clip taken from a longer post
from the former president
just posted on his social
it's called election interference.
They're trying to destroy a reputation
so they can win an election
that's just as bad as doing
any of the other things
that have been done
over the last number of years.
I'm an innocent man.
I did nothing wrong. I'm innocent.
And we will prove that very,
very soundly.
And hopefully very quickly.
I want to talk more about the possible
charges, Ellie.
Maggie Haberman was reporting
conspiracy to obstruct
false statements,
willful retention of defense information.
So few really important
indicators in Maggie's reporting
that she just gave us on air.
First of all,
Maggie reported
that there is a document retention charge
and that tells us
that this is not all obstruction.
There have been some question.
Is this only going to be
an obstruction case?
No.
According to Maggie's reporting,
there's a document retention
charge or charges.
And separately, as Maggie just reported,
there's an obstruction angle.
So it's not all about obstruction
documents and obstruction.
Maggie also reported
she just told us that
none of the charges are the same.
You can have in a federal indictment
multiple counts of the same crime,
four counts of obstruction, etc..
This tells us that there are, again,
according to Maggie's reporting, seven
different counts.
We know one of them is conspiracy
from prior reporting.
And then the last thing that
Maggie tells us
is that there's an obstruction count
and a false statements count,
meaning somebody
in Trump's
camp or Donald Trump himself knew about
or made
or authorized the false statement,
presumably either to archives or to DOJ
so we're getting indicators
from Maggie, and Paul is reporting.
Robert Ray, you were former
Whitewater independent counsel.
What do you make of what we've heard
thus far?
I think the venue was probably one
that the Department of Justice
felt that they were stuck with,
because I think there are charges
contained in this indictment
that could only have been brought
in the Southern District of Florida.
So I think that's sort
of the first significant thing.
What would those what would that be?
Probably the obstruction
that things that happened in Mar a Lago
that only could have have happened in Mar
a Lago,
that they are charging
those things that happened in Mar a Lago.
And if that's
the gravamen
of a particular charge,
that would be the only place
that charges could be brought.
And then I think
the related to that
is because it is
in the southern district of Florida.
And although there is a court appearance
scheduled in Miami,
I think for administrative reasons,
you would expect this case
if it is centered around Mar
a Lago, to be one that would draw
from a Palm Beach County jury pool
and a judge assigned
to that particular Visnic Why is that?
Because, again, that's where the
that's where
the alleged crime is
is alleged to have taken place.
And you would expect, therefore, to
for the case under the Constitution
that the cases
brought in the district nearest
to where the charges
is is located and filed
and where the the facts are.
So the defendant has a right
to a jury pool from that location.
And that location happens to be Palm
Beach County.
The
I think the the jurisdiction,
as you say, is critical to this.
The jury pool is critical.
The the charges are critical.
And as Maggie has reported, seven charges
including, you know, conspiracy
to obstruct,
obstruction of justice, false statements.
This is not just one charge
of alleged witch hunt by prosecutors.
This is quite serious.
But here's the thing.
We have a jury of law
that is going after him,
which is quite serious.
But Donald Trump
is trying to make his case,
whether it's on social
or with his people.
I have a friend
that met with him yesterday in Bedminster
He is not worried about this whatsoever.
He is relaxed.
He is resolute.
He is telling his people
he has done nothing wrong.
He is innocent.
This is a witch hunt.
And here's the thing.
There's going to be two competing
factions here.
There is the court of law,
which is quite serious
and is going to come down
heavy and hard on Donald Trump
in the next few days.
And then what?
Donald Trump
thinks he's
going to get away
with the court of public opinion
in the political spectrum
and his base
and his supporters
are going to support him.
Whatever he says,
they're going to believe him
and they are doubling down
and he will be
more emboldened with his base on this.
But these are serious charges.
And when this comes down,
the the heavy arm of the law
is going to be swift and firm.
Donald Trump,
just in terms of the
stock, going to be so swift.
That's a big question.
Historic nature of this.
What do you mean? How do you see this?
Look, I.
I will believe it when I see it,
but I find it hard to
imagine how there is going to be
a trial of these charges,
which is what one would ordinarily expect
sometime next year,
which happens to be 20, 24
and an election cycle.
The charges are serious enough,
and the evidence
seems to be voluminous enough
that I wouldn't
think this would be a two or three
day trial.
This is likely to be a two or three week
or longer trial.
And I cannot imagine
under the Constitution
where the defendant is required
and has the obligation to be present
and has a right to be present
that he's going to take.
And I'll be afforded
two to three weeks
to sit in a courtroom trying
this case in 20, 24 on top of which
the Manhattan
DA's office
this case is another
probably two or three week trial.
I just don't see how we are going
to have trials next year.
The former president, I don't see that.
I think the lawyers for right now
agree with it.
I do agree with that analysis.
Actually,
you have to think about this practically.
Okay.
We have a trial date
in the Manhattan case
late March, March 25th.
That's going to take it into April.
You have to build in some time
to prep for each case.
No way that I can see that
this federal case gets tried before that.
You'd have to start in January
or February.
That's not going to be enough time.
Trump is going to fight this.
He's going to bring motions.
There's going to be voluminous discovery.
So now we're saying, okay,
if the Manhattan DA case holds
March into April,
you can't just have Back-To-Back
trials, as Robert said.
You have a constitutional right
to prepare your defense
to participate in your defense.
So you have to build an even more time.
Now, we're aware a year from now,
the summer of 2024,
when we're right upon conventions,
when we're months away
from an actual presidential election.
I don't think a judge
is going to do that.
If I'm a prosecutor,
I don't want to try this case
consistent with DOJ policy,
but also as a strategic matter
in, let's say, August, September.
20, 20. Can I just ask a question?
What if Donald Trump were elected
president?
Then what happens?
Well, this is gone.
Yeah.
Because,
first of all,
he would control the Justice Department.
So if you're talking about this case,
he controls the Justice Department.
Just he just dismisses the the
if it's still pending,
he dismisses the case. It's gone.
Couldn't he pardon himself?
Well, there's a debate about that.
But if it's a pending case,
he just basically withdraws
the authority of the United States
behind the prosecution.
And he has the opposite absolute right
to do that.
The conversation we just heard
is a conversation
that lawyers had with Donald
Trump months ago.
Oh, I'm sure that's right.
James, why he threw his hat in the ring.
This explains the whole deal.
He has game this thing out
and he thinks he's
going to get away with it.
What I would say
to everybody who's watching this,
nobody is seeing this indictment
We don't know what's in it.
Republicans are jumping out
there saying this is all about, you know,
Joe Biden.
Joe Biden had nothing to do with this,
a special prosecutor.
This is not a porn star thing.
This isn't robbing
the piggy bank of your charity.
This is a federal government
talking about possible espionage
and a presidential candidate
that has game this thing out
to get away with it
by running for office.
If that's what's happening here,
we should take this very, very seriously.
And I think I think people do it.
People on this table
and a lot of people in America do.
But Alisyn, myself and others
on the Republican side,
we're talking to our friends
and the writer Die Trumpers. Right.
They want to abolish the FBI.
They don't trust the FBI.
They don't trust any of this stuff.
And this is Deep
State coming after the president.
So this doesn't
it is not going to matter.
They're going to have a big rally
for Saturday's
going to have a big rally
in Georgia, North Carolina.
I promise
when he shows up on Tuesday,
it'll look like a Trump
rally outside that Miami-Dade.
If you remember the Brooks Brothers
rally in 2000,
that'll look like a Boy Scout camp
compared to what's going to happen.
And this is
this to me,
when constitutional conservatives
need to stand up,
at a certain point,
people have to be
clear when we have a system of laws.
There's a reason
to the special prosecutor.
This was not the normal.
Listen, if that's a normal thing,
it was handled in an inappropriate way.
They took a very long time to do this.
And I don't understand
how you can be a patriot
and at the same time, stand
by while people
are running into the ground.
Law enforcement
running it into the ground, our system.
But but,
Van, Donald Trump's
whole political project
has been to disqualify
rules, laws, norms and institutions,
to disqualify the media,
to disqualify the FBI,
to disqualify the Justice Department
for the express purpose of being able
to make the case when these things come,
that this is a corrupt system.
And the question is
how much takeup will they have?
I suspect among his base,
that's going to happen
just minutes,
at least
minutes, I guess, after
this indictment was announced,
Jim Jordan was already tweeting,
this is a sad day for America.
And we'll see what happens tomorrow.
But I expect to see
a lot of House Republicans
sort of galvanized here
and attacking the Justice
Department and why?
Look, this is espionage,
potential espionage here.
This is absolutely serious.
But we can all remember back
before January six, Steve Bannon telling
the world.
Hell, will break out on January six.
I'm not
convinced that the
exact same thing is not going to happen
when all of this becomes public.
And all of those people
that were at the Capitol on January 6th
will all have hell breaking loose,
whether it is in South Florida
or Washington, D.C., ten times more.
I know it may not be sufficient
for many, but, you know,
I understand that
the former president also has limits.
The public doesn't seem to
recognize that.
But he will obey process.
He will appear at 3 p.m.
in Miami courthouse to answer
the federal charges next week.
He's not ignoring the process.
He didn't ignore the process
before the Manhattan DA's office.
He has the right to dispute the
the merits of a prosecution,
which he is fully going to do.
Is he going to take advantage
of the political process? You bet.
And you would expect him to do so.
I don't think the country
is going to fall
to pieces
as a result of the fact that he is going
to contest these charges.